uh my doctor told me not to punch so
many people yeah well i mean that goes
without saying probably
it's probably bad for everyone if you do
that um but i like the pick yeah i like
it yeah i would watch i'd watch a dark
hbo series about that
yeah i'd watch it just to be clear did i
just accidentally pitch an episode of
rick and morty
tom
what is a teen tv character you'd like
to see as a grown up
well my friends if we're talking about
teen
tv characters that we're going to see as
grown-ups
pardon me which we are
and we ought
are we interrupting your lunch i'm sorry
what happened
i have a mint
friends if we're talking about teen tv
characters that we want to see growing
up i want to i want to paint you a
picture so imagine
that you were you write
for a website
okay i'm imagining it crazy okay so you
get sent out on a story it turns out
there's this charismatic dude who's
living in the middle of the forest let's
say in southern oregon somewhere
with a small group of people who they
they've sort of
i don't know they've started orbiting
him they they all believe in what he's
saying they say that he's saying some
great things and nobody can quite figure
out what it is that he's preaching so he
gets sent down to go and talk to this
dude
and uh it turns out
the guy that you meet he's got like a
big old man bun he's living in this
peaceful sort of idyllic natural
community
he says his name is mati
and that 30 years ago
i know the spirit of the planet earth
gaia
uh came to him and four other people and
said that they were responsible
for taking care of the planet from now
on that they were the guardians the
stewards of the planet and sometimes
mother earth sounded like the lady from
the view and sometimes she sounded like
lois lane from the superman movies but
what really mattered was that she gave
everybody jewelry that let them control
some aspect of the natural experience
and that he was given the ability
to control the the hearts and minds of
of men and animals
and that as a result of that
uh
he now deserves to be in charge of all
of these people and then you say well
that's really interesting i'm gonna go
and he's like nah stay and you're like
no really i gotta go and then he's like
no
stay
and all of a sudden you feel compelled
to stick around this community guys i
think um i think you know this about me
i'm fascinated by like
stories about characters who are granted
like these fantastic abilities and like
what that would do to them later on
down the road or these phenomenal
experiences like we talked about um
it's a wonderful life a while ago
and how i don't think that that george
wound up being probably a very good
person
after he had this experience
where the actual literal god said you're
you're a great dude like
and i i i would be further fascinated to
learn what happened to like on
on that same note
i would be amazed to find out what
happened to the planeteers after
the whole captain planet thing was over
clearly they didn't win right like the
planet's still like dying at a faster
pace than it was worse than ever
yeah
so so bad right really really bad it's
bad yeah
it's not great so i would love to find
out what happened to these five
children who were uh given control of
the elements
and they told that they were responsible
for fixing the planet yeah because like
what have they been up to for the past
couple decades
right like exactly was it nothing
maybe it was nothing maybe it was fat
nothing yeah we don't know right maybe
they were actively doing damage yeah
probably had to get their rings resized
because they've yeah as they grew yeah
yeah you would hope yeah yeah yeah
some of them are like i just don't like
this style anymore they just stopped
wearing their rings it's kind of bulky
yeah they're bulky rings i mean when you
look at them they're kind of bulky
looking exactly it makes me look like a
jerk i'm walking around but yeah no like
you're an adult
they go to college they're like but i
like my class ring better yeah yeah
that kind of thing furthermore like i
don't i feel like there are a ton of
unanswered questions uh in that
mythology i would i would just love an
exploration of them
where's captain planet what's he doing
is he
yeah yeah i don't think for the whole
series but yeah yeah
for a little while yeah
so in the recent season of rick and
morty they actually kind of dive into
this a bit did you see that who they
yeah there's an episode
yet
morty falls in love with planet tina
that is a female version of captain
planet and he encounters all of the
current adult planeteers and they are
very uh they're more like brand managers
they're not particularly interested in
saving the planet so much as they are in
managing planetana's brand it's pretty
it's pretty bleak looking it's bleak i
won't spoil it but i mean it goes about
as well as you think it would in an
episode of rick and morty so not great
yeah so everyone who's watching this
video now and who's seen that episode is
probably typing into the comments about
everything that happened in that episode
so you could stop now we know we know
what happens um but yeah no i think that
is a good idea i think it would be fun
to revisit the captain planet idea in
2021
uh to see the ways in which they failed
and maybe the ways in which they're
trying to succeed i don't know it always
seemed kind of weird that captain
planet's one weakness was pollution when
that was the thing he was supposed to
stop
and that was yeah really his wall yeah
right was there no like allergy
medication he could take to deal with
the pollution thing like
clean up
i'm here to clean up ah it got on me i'm
weak
that's like if you're if you're batman
but every time you punch a criminal
you're like oh no my one weakness
criminals
one weakness punching yeah
my doctor told me not to punch so many
people yeah well i mean that goes
without saying you probably
it's probably bad for everyone if you do
that um but i like the pick yeah i like
it yeah i would watch i'd watch a dark
hbo series about that
yeah i'd watch it just to be clear did i
just accidentally pitch an episode of
rick and morty like was that was that
the plot of an episode of rick and morty
not entirely it's not the book of the
episode but yeah a little bit you're
rick and morty adjacent yeah i think
it's good though so so nina what about
you what's what's your pick for this
topic
uh well i looked at uh the article that
we're talking about today and
for a second i almost picked gossip girl
but i didn't for two reasons one is that
i thought you would both just leave if i
started talking about gossip girl
extensively potentially and two they
already we already know what would
happen to uh the person who turned out
to be gossip girl as an adult because
you is a tv show and he just graduated
from cyber stalking to murder so we
already have an answer to that i mean
honestly like
joe from you is if dan humphrey murdered
people because he's just as manipulative
and creepy
but he just there's more blood so
what i ended up picking uh is we kind of
got an answer to this but i still think
we could do more with it because the
answer is a little old now
is the cast of freaks and geeks
um
yeah so i uh in 2012 um paul feig
you know kind of talked about what would
have happened to the characters after
the series ended and it's like i think
he said uh lindsay would be a lawyer
um and eventually like sam would have
joined drama
and he was like daniel would be in jail
um
yeah and so he had
yeah that does track and so he had all
these answers but i still think
you know i mean we all know freaks and
geeks we all love freaks and geeks one
of the best
teenage casts in
not television history history period i
mean every person who appeared on that
show even like people who appeared in
the background like lizzie kaplan are
like very famous now rashida jones
she was over jones
right that's right and so it's just like
you know
to have and and it was also cancelled
way before its time and you know it's
canceled what it's like lindsay's
getting on the
on the bus on the bus to go see that or
whatever right she's gonna go like
follow the dead around the country and
lizzie phillips right and so it's just
like not only do i think like i want to
see all these people work together again
especially with paul feig because i love
paul feig so much but
um
i just i think that it would be
fascinating to find out like what
actually happened to them i mean i still
i would like to stick with
james franco's daniel being in jail i
think that i don't think you can improve
he doesn't
and that would be fine but like hey guys
gather around i got another letter from
daniel
he's still in he's still in prison yeah
oh no but like i want to see what
happened to jason siegel's like sweet
doofy nick yeah i want to see you ever
learn to play the drums better
right and and in terms of like the
alternate universe thing i i touched on
with gossip girl new i'm curious like
which linda cartellini do we think
lindsay weir is do we think that she is
the dead to me linda cartellini do we
think that she is uh the knife wielding
a simple favor linda cardellini do we
think that she's
the legally blonde linda carlini like
there's a lot of options do we think
she's the mcu linda cartellini there's
so many i think she's
a hero she's just kidding me right now i
was so that was gonna be my last thing
is does she just become velma and
everything everything takes a very weird
shift but yeah i i don't think i need to
explain why i want to see like the cast
of freaks and geeks reunite as adults
and hang out together and show us where
they ended up i don't i don't think
anyone's like why'd she pick that i
think we'd all like to see where they
ended that'd be awesome with judd apatow
and paul feig at the
yeah it kind of tracks that she left so
that she could go and watch the grateful
dead across the country and then turned
into a member of mystery inc like that's
that's as reasonable an origin story for
that group of people
exactly like
exactly you spend a summer following the
dead around the country and then by the
end of it you're like we need to find
ghosts
and this dog can talk also
on a not that note but something that
like occurred to me is you know everyone
thought like busy phelps kim kelly was
the burnout and you know lindsay where
was the genius but like you know in the
gilmore girls revival rory gilmore the
you know wonderkind of stars hollow is a
huge failure so what if lindsay weirs
like a burnout and kim kelly is like
running a company
and is like a ceo and in charge of
everything like what if you know what if
we could see if you're being like
representative that's doing that
i actually can see her bullying people
into letting her run
lularoe she's getting just like owning
the entire company
i want to see grown-up bill i want to
see right star yes
one star grew into a very cool dude
so cool
but bill is like always kind of hunched
over he's like the turbo nerd yes
exactly the ur geek yeah i didn't mean
to focus so much on the the freak side
of freaks and geeks because the geeks
are so fun to and like i love sam levine
like all of these people i want to see
you know they don't daily
a screenwriter now but he's like no like
so let him grow really tall he's really
tall i let him play a screenwriter that
would be cool yeah it would be great
yeah yeah yeah and there's that
is uh what's his name isn't count floyd
right mm-hmm are you either and they're
moms this is what i'm saying yeah
yes and then they're they're
their mom is becky ann baker who plays
the mom in every tv show
right she's just everyone's mom
yeah yeah uh uh lindsay and and um
what is what is what is uh
john daly's character's name it's
disappeared from my brain already sam
lindsey lindsey and sam thank you yeah
oh cause i got confused because neil is
his actor yes yeah yeah
all right i'm back on track no they find
out that lena dunham is their half
sister i was just gonna say hannah
horvath half sister yeah their mom
remarried
and their mom doesn't want to fund their
half-sister's groovy new york lifestyle
anymore and then it just yeah it all
kicks off in there what would the adult
freaks and geeks revival be called like
haters and losers or something freakier
and geekier freakier
that's we can workshop that too we have
a lot of work shopping perfect something
different freakier
[Laughter]
it's just called reddit yeah
it's just going oh my back hurts because
they're all oh no
that's great i love it i would watch
that you know honestly though i think
we're probably a few years out from
seeing that i'm really hoping yeah if
tomorrow they announced the freaks and
geeks revival on netflix or hulu or any
of these streaming services people would
freak out they'd lose their minds if
they did it with wet hot american summer
why can't they do with freaks and geeks
yeah for sure that's all i'm saying
one good thing though to say about that
show that got canceled after only one
season is that you have one perfect
season
it's terrific pretty great and you don't
have to be like don't watch this other
stuff when it got bad or i didn't like
it when this character left or whatever
right
just have a perfect little story that
has a beginning so yeah a reboot could
be very dangerous but i think it's
enough time has passed and everyone in
that cast is so cool and talented that
they'd be able to probably whip
something and also half the cast is now
like professional screenwriters yeah
john francis daly and jason siegel have
both written a ton of movies so
yeah so okay so i'm gonna hop in and
talk a little bit more specifically
about the article that we have on
looper.com teen tv characters we want to
see us grown up so
one of them top one blossom
from blossom
we are kind of seeing her as a grown up
now she grew up to host jeopardy
so there you go we could just move that
move on from that one
or she became amy from the big bang
theory right exactly right a name of a
character i don't know because it's a
show i don't watch
i like that about you uh bing bong
theory dawson from dawson's creek we
know what happened to him because he was
in don't trust the b in apartment 23
although james van der beek not dawson
but still close enough
and also he became a popular internet
meme
yeah right wouldn't that be great if
dawson grew up and then found out that
his face was oh no
like star wars all of his confidence
yeah
discovered that the whole world has been
laughing at him for the last 20 years
for sure
started eating his feelings he ballooned
up to 400 pounds and started
poor dolphins
tia and tamara from sister sister is a
good one that's a show i watched and
enjoyed as a as a young man because i
watched everything that was on tv for
the most part at that point now i know i
think that both of those those actors
are still working as actors today so i'm
sure if they announced i believe that
they are i think they probably i think
they do like tv movies and stuff
what if they did a sister sister revival
on disney plus and each of them had
twins
oh man
sister sister sister sister sister
sister wow america's ready
that's a lot oh they are they're both
still acting um one of them
they did a reality show one of them
hosts a talk show yeah and i think one
of them did like didn't they do like a
movie about like witches called like
twitches or something like twin wins
you know what if they didn't then they
could in the future so now yeah
another one on this list seth cohen from
the oc a show i did not watch but the
actor i did
tell us about seth cohen from the oc i
don't know anything oh my first love
seth cohen um he
i'm not kidding he's so he's one of
those teens who he's supposed to be the
loser but he's like so classically
handsome that you're like come on it's
got andrew garfield spider-man syndrome
no and and he's also like he's like i
like comic books and video games i'm
like yeah everyone likes that stuff like
he starts a comic book club at school
and he gets one member and i'm like that
would never happen ever yeah um but he's
uh he's a really funny character he gets
some of the best lines in the show very
quick-witted very sharp really good like
repartee between him and other
characters
a
a seminal team character
there is a movie yeah
i'm sorry to cut you off oh no there's a
movie called the kid detective starring
adam brody
which in which he plays a a grown
basically a grown-up seth detective seth
right right so so i don't know how much
there's overlap between that character
and his character and the kid detective
but the kid detective is excellent i
just hope he didn't grow up into his
character from ready or not because that
that would be pretty bleak
i like that movie a whole lot but yeah
um i'm not gonna spoil it here it's a
good fun movie but i hope he did not
grow up into that character so but the
character so i know i've just run
through a whole bunch of characters and
one of them that's on this list is steve
urkel who wouldn't want to see a
grown-up steve urkel anyway
uh the character i think has the most
potential here
is paige jennings from the americans
have you guys watched the americans
not all the way through but i do i have
seen paige a whole bunch and i also live
on the internet so i know what happens
at the end of the series right so i'm
gonna i'm gonna spoil it for you tom
sorry not sorry it has been it's been on
for a long time um
so so paige is the daughter of these two
soviet spies who are undercover in
america and eventually she figures out
that her parents are spies
and
she joins them and becomes a spy as well
and so it ends with
yeah so it ends with them
leaving the country to go back to
russia
and paige is going to go with them but
she's never
even been to russia
so she bails on them at the canadian
border and leaves and stays in america
and we don't know what happens to her at
the end so it's the last the last shot
of the show is um are the two parents
back in russia basically like wondering
what's going on with their kids back in
america and we don't know what's going
and so their son is like basically gonna
be like he's fine well not fine i mean
his parents abandoned him but he's like
he's innocent but paige is like a
fugitive right she's been drawn into the
fold right yeah it would be amazing to
see a follow-up series to see what paige
has been up to and what she's kind of
gotten up to like you know they're
reviving dexter which had you know which
notoriously
people hate it by the end and so they've
and
didn't the americans receive like
universal acclaim for the finale i
remember
the finale was on like every year and
best of list that year everyone was
loved it was one of the few shows that
was
basically amazing from beginning to end
because it was what four or five seasons
it was not particularly long yeah
something like that yeah it's definitely
something that you could kind of get it
i mean you know i've just ruined the
entire ending so i'm sorry but yeah i
would love to see what paige is up to as
an adult and just see like how is she
getting a lot especially since you know
those the soviet union collapses right
here in america she has to like take on
an assumed identity even though she was
born and raised in america and so like
what's you know what she had to deal
with since then did she go to work for
american intelligence eventually when is
the original plot set
it's in the 80s it's in the 80s oh so
she'd have to okay so she'd have to
navigate the 90s
and like the turn of the next century oh
that's cool i would watch that and like
you see her like wearing slap bracelets
and that's got the microfiche in it or
something
maybe she could grow up and fight sydney
bristow even though their ages don't
line up at all
sure i could see yeah the alias
crossover you never know
exactly
perfect yeah i love it
you had me at combination slap bracelet
microfiber
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe bye
[Music]
you